المترجم: Nawal Sharabati
المدقّق: Riyad Almubarak
(تصفيق)
في عام 2012 أصيبت فتاة صغيرة بمرض السحايا.
وبفضل الله وثم اكتشاف العالم فلمنج
لأول مضاد حيوي وهو البنسلين
ما كانت اليوم هذه الفتاة واقفة أمامكم.
أنا يارا بهران عمري 11 سنة
في الصف السادس
ويلقبوني بعدة ألقاب: أنا العجوزة،
والفيلسوفة، وأنا الفضولية، وأرسطو.
(تصفيق)
وحضرت اليوم لأروي لكم
كيف أحببتُ العلم مثلما أحب الشوكولاتة.
يحبُ أغلبية الأطفال الشوكولاتة،
حتى أنا كذلك.
لو قلتُ لكم ذات يوم بأن هذه شوكولاته،
ولم تكونوا قد رأيتموها في حياتكم قبل ذلك
سترون أن لونها بني، وشكلها غريب،
ولن تتحمسوا لتذوقها.
لكن لو قلت لكم من أين جاءت هذه الشوكولاتة،
وشرحتُ لكم بأنها عبارة عن بذرة غرسناها،
وقمنا بسقايتها حتى كبرت، وأثمرت لنا كاكاو
وجمعناه وصنعنا منه هذه الشوكولاتة.
وقلت لكم أنها لذيذة وتذوبُ بالفم،
ورائحتها مشهية، ستبدأون بالتحمس لتذوقها،
نفس الشيء العقل الذي هو بذرة
نغرسه بأول معلومة نتعلمها
ونبدأ بسقيه بالعلم لغاية ما يكير
ويثمر لنا.
وهذه الثمار هي الاختراعات والاكتشافات
التي توصل إليها العلماء،
وبفضلها أصبحت حياتنا أسهل وأفضل.
مثل: الاتصالات والسيارات والطائرات،
والكهرباء والحاسوب،
كل هذه اختراعات واكتشافات.
ولكي تحبوا العلم مثلي،
ومن أجل أن نتعرف على العلم أكثر
هيا بنا نسافرُ في رحلة تطور العلم.
سنعودُ الآن إلى الماضي،
إلى أيام الإنسان القديم الذي هو رجل الكهف
كانت حياة رجل الكهف صعبة،
وكان يحتاجُ إلى أن يأكل ويتدفأ
وكان يرغبُ في العيش، لذلك شغّل عقله
ونمّى شجرته لغاية ما كبرت وأثمرت لنا.
ومن ثم كان من هذه الثمار
اكتشاف النار واختراع أدوات الصيد.
وبعد فترة من الزمن، اكتشف الإنسان الزراعة،
وانتقل الناس إلى مناطق الأنهار
وبنيت الحضارات ومنها
الحضارة الفرعونية في نهر النيل.
لكن لم يكن عند اليمنيين نهر
ليسقوا نباتاتهم طوال العام
ففكروا وشغّلوا عقولهم
ونمّوا أشجارهم بالعلم لغاية ما أثمرت
وكان من هذه الثمار
بناء السدود وقنوات الري،
وبهذه الطريقة بنيت
الحضارة اليمنية العظيمة.
(تصفيق)
قرر أيضًا العالم الحسن بن الهيثم
أن يسقي شجرته بالعلم،
وقام بسقيها إلى أن كبرت وأثمرت لنا.
وكانت نظرية الضوء والانعكاس من هذه الثمار
التي تم بفضلها اختراع الكاميرا
وتطور طب العيون.
وبفضل هذه النظرية،
فإنني أراكم بوضوح وأرتدي نظارات طبية.
(تصفيق)
كان عند توماس أديسون إرادة ودافع
لاختراع المصباح الكهربائي.
هل تعرفوا من أين جاءت له الإرادة والدافع؟
سأروي لكم حكايته لمعرفة ذلك.
كما قيل، مرضت والدة توماس أديسون
في إحدى الليالي،
فقرروا إجراء عملية جراحية لها
ولعدم وجود الضوء،
أجلوا هذه العملية إلى الصباح
وتعرضت حياتها إلى الخطر.
وعندها قرر توماس أديسون
أن يسقي شجرته بالعلم.
وقام بسقيها إلى أن أثمرت،
وكان المصباح الكهربائي من هذه الثمار.
(تصفيق)
أرأيتم كيف عاش رجل الكهف
بفضل العلم ولم ينقرض.
وبنيت بفضل العلم الحضارات
ومنها الحضارة اليمنية العظيمة.
واستمتعنا بفضل العلم
بالمصباح الكهربائي في الليل.
وتم بفضل العلم اختراح الكاميرا
التي تصورني الآن.
وبفضل التكنولوجيا الحديثة
أصبحت حياتنا أسهل وأفضل.
حسنًا! ليس لزامًا علينا...
تخيلوا حياتنا دون هذه الثمار،
دون الاختراعات، دون الكهرباء والاتصالات،
دون الأدوية والحاسوب،
ودون الطائرات.
تخيلوا مدى صعوبة حياتنا.
لذلك علينا ليس فقط تقدير العلم،
علينا أن نحبه ونتعلمه بحب!
أتعرفون لماذا؟
لأننا مع كل درس نتعلمه في المدرسة،
يروي لنا قصة حياة عالم،
أفنى حياته بالكامل ليوصل لنا هذا الدرس
بطريقة سهلة ولذيذة مثل الشوكولاتة.
(تصفيق)
وعلينا أن نقول شكرًا،
شكراً لكل العلماء الذين أهدونا ثمار علمهم
شوكولاتة سهلة لذيذة نستفيد منها،
ونستمتع فيها.
شكرًا لكم، فأنا أحبكم وأقدركم
وتأكدوا بأنني سأنهي مشواركم.
وسأطور هذا العلم.
(تصفيق)
حُلمي أن أكون مخترعة عندما أكبر
لأجعل حياة الإنسان أسهل وأفضل
مثلما فعل العلماء من قبلي.
(تصفيق)
ستسألونني، يا يارا: كيف ستنمي شجرتك
لتثمر لنا اختراعات
ولكي تكوني مخترعة؟
سأقول لكم كيف ذلك،
لكي أنمّي شجرتي لتثمر لنا اختراعات
فإنني أسأل دومًا.
أسأل وأبحثُ عن إجابات لأسئلتي
وأسئلة الأطفال لأنها مماثلة لأسئلة العلماء
لكن ظل العلماء يبحثون عن إجاباب لأسئلتهم.
أجربُ دومًا كل شيء، لأنني لو لم أجرب
فلن أعرف ما هو مجال إبداعي.
تعلمتُ أن لا أخاف من الخطأ
لأن الخطأ فرصة رائعة للتعلم.
ظل توماس أديسون يحاول 999 مرة
قبل أن ينجح في اختراع المصباح الكهربائي
ونجح في المرة الألف.
ولم يكن يسميها محاولات فاشلة، بل محاولات
لم تنجح ساعدتني في الاختراع.
أحب القراءة لأنني بالقراءة أغوص المحيطات،
وأصعد الفضاء وأدخل الصحاري،
وأدخل الغابات وأنا في مكانٍ واحد.
(تصفيق)
العلم بالنسبة لي متعة! لأنني أستمتع بدروسي
في المدرسة، وأتخيلُ درس الجغرافيا
وكأنني ركبتُ بساط علاء الدين
ورأيتُ التضاريس والخرائط تحتي.
أتخيل درس التاريخ، وكأنني رجعت إلى الماضي،
لأيام عصر الحضارات القديمة.
أتخيلُ درس العلوم تجارب مثيرة،
وأتخيلُ درس الرياضيات ألعاب وألغاز.
استمتعوا! استمتعوا بالعلم الذي تتعلمونه
لأنكم إذا استمتعتم به، ستبدعون فيه.
دعونا ننمي شجرتنا لتكبر وتثمر كاكاو
ونجمع هذا الكاكاو ونصنع منه شوكولاته.
ليس أنتم فقط من سيستفيد منها،
لكن ستستفيد البشرية جمعاء.
فدعونا نستبدل السلاح بالعلم.
دعونا نتعلم بحب لكي نبني وطننا بحب.
فبالسلاح نهدم الوطن وبالعلم نبنيه.
(تصفيق)